[Music]
foreign
for climate change what I'm really
arguing for is is dedicated
absolute top of the range super
Computing which these days is exascale
10 to the 18 flops per second floating
Point operations per second dedicated to
climate change and that's not happening
at the moment anywhere around the world
if I'm talking to a climate skeptic I
would say look you
surely are as interested as I am or as a
climate you know somebody that's very
concerned about climate change to know
the truth you know how bad is it going
to get well solving the laws of physics
uh is the only way we have to deal with
this we can answer this question there's
no laboratory experiment we can do
to emulate climate change
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
Welcome Friends to another wonderful
edition of the into the impossible
podcast with our guest Tim Palmer the
Royal Society research professor in the
department of physics at the University
of Oxford who pioneered the development
of operational Ensemble weather and
climate forecasting and in 2007 was
formally recognized as having
contributed to the intergovernmental
panel on climate change and received a
recognition for that via the Nobel Prize
the Nobel Peace Prize that he shared
along with many other scientists and
also former vice president Al Gore and
there's a lot of connection here in San
Diego at the Scripps institution of
oceanography all sorts of good stuff
many many good connections but this will
be part of our continuing sequence of
think like a Nobel Prize winner although
I can't say that Tim is my first
non-physics Nobel Prize winner he's he
didn't win it in physics not yet at
least but he did at least participate in
the uh in the peace process you're my
first Peace Prize co-recipient so Tim uh
thank you so much for joining us on this
auspicious occasion of the publication
of this wonderful book thank you it's a
pleasure thank you so we've had on a
fair number of oxonians we've had on a
fair number of uh of physicists that
focus on the biggest picture topics one
could imagine and uh you were actually
referred to me uh by our mutual friend
Sabina hasenfelder who is a recent guest
on the podcast with whom you've written
some wonderful works with and uh with
whom you and I co-recorded a video this
actually our second video together we
did a very very technical uh expository
video on the differences between British
English and American English back uh on
the first of the year or thereabouts so
we'll put a link to that somewhere up
here down there wherever so it's our
second time together Tim but uh this
time time it's synchronized so we can
actually have a conversation so as I
mentioned what I love to do is talk
about books on this podcast and I love
to uh to discuss the thought process
behind the book and kind of we'll get
into your process you're remarkably
productive and and I want to get into
your habits and we have a lot of young
scientists that listen to this podcast
and learning from folks like you who do
so much in so many different fields from
Gravity to the brain to God we're going
to get into it all and of course chaos
and climate change I want to ask you
where did the title of the book come to
you from uh I understand that took some
figuring out and the subtitle which
involves our chaotic world and and most
importantly for us visual Learners what
is the uh depiction the illustration on
the cover meant to evoke in the reader's
Minds
foreign
okay well there's there's quite a few
questions sort of tied up there uh let
me start by saying that you know uh you
you've talked about my or at least
mentioned my work on climate change but
I've I've had a fairly I would say kind
of broad type of career and I started
life off
uh after my undergraduate degree in in
mathematics and physics uh doing a PhD
in general relativity Theory so I
actually had started off thinking that
my you know life's work would be in
fundamental physics
but I kind of reevaluated things after
the PHD and uh
you know partly because I I met some
people by chance in the climate area and
I I kind of felt that I needed to do
something let's say a bit more
um you know that could have some impact
let's say on on the human species or
some parts of it at least
um so but working in in weather and
climate you know you realize that
weather and climate pretty much affect
everything in life you know from the
economy uh through to health
uh through to you know uh whether we
have enough food and water to uh to eat
and drink so that in turn got me kind of
interested in all these Downstream
application Sciences
and I was kind of I think it was at the
beginning of probably at the beginning
of the pandemic uh I was trying to think
is there a theme that that kind of
unifies everything that I've done and
the notion of uncertainty uh kind of
came up
in my head and that got started me
starting to think whether I could try to
write a popular book sort of loosely
speaking about the science of
uncertainty but kind of discussing it
through a range of topics that I've been
involved with one way or another
um
uh so and then the the actual title the
Primacy of doubt
um was actually taken from a
um a book that uh James Glick wrote a
very famous biography of Richard Feynman
um and Glick is somebody I've known
because he prior to that Roto absolutely
wonderful book uh about Chaos Theory it
really actually you know he he actually
coined the phrase the butterfly effect
um in in the book uh this is back in the
uh 1980s I think yeah um so I was aware
of James Glick and his his his fantastic
ability to to explain things clearly
um and that got me interested in his
biography of Feynman and then I came
across this quote in in that biography
that about Feynman and Glick says uh he
believed he Feynman believed in the
Primacy of Doubt not as a blemish on our
ability to know but as the essence of
knowing and I just thought that was such
a wonderful phrase
um
you know the the notion that The Human
Condition is one of uncertainty and our
creativity comes from being you know
uncertain about things and that notion
that the Primacy of doubt I I thought
that really resonated with me and it and
it's been a kind of a I suppose a
philosophy of mine that
um
that uncertainty uh you know is
something that you have to put right up
front and foremost also depicted on the
cover reminded me of glick's book chaos
because it seems to have well it's a
very attractive cover let me say uh so
uh what is the uh the object depicted on
the cover and what is its relevance to
quantum physics and climate change
right
um the the front cover is a depiction of
what is sometimes called a strange
attractor which sounds a kind of a
bizarre uh words to use but it's
I would say I you see I it's it's what
you would call the geometry of Chaos
and it's something that I think you know
Lawrence Ed lorentz who was the uh
discoverer of this geometry of chaos
should actually himself have won a Nobel
Prize
um so what what Lawrence discovered was
three very simple uh mathematical
equations
um that you know you could you could I
mean these days they're so easy to solve
they you know they used as screensavers
on computers in his day they in his day
he had to actually get some pretty
chunky Computing to to solve them but
what he what he found was that
um when he ran these equations over long
periods of time on the computer and
plotted the the state so there are three
variables so if you want to describe the
state of the of the system you need a
three it's a point in a
three-dimensional space which you call
State space
and um you run your model and you look
at you know how do these points evolve
and you find that they evolve on this
rather strange uh geometry which is the
shown in the front cover of the book
and lorentz was the one that realized uh
that this geometry actually is a fractal
it's a fractal in the sense that if you
zoom into it as much as you like
um you'll still you'll see the same kind
of structures uh appearing and
reappearing and this is completely the
complete antithesis of the sort of
classical euclidean geometry that we're
all taught about at school and stuff
which like a sphere the surface of a
sphere
um which just gets really boring if you
zoom into it enough it just looks flat
and uninteresting so these fractals are
distinguished
um by never running out of structure on
the small scale and actually as a result
of that you need a different type of
mathematics to really describe the
geometry of these fractals uh and I've
my whole you know pretty much my life
has has evolved around either
understanding these fractals or trying
to kind of elucidate properties of them
uh and a lot of the work I've done on
predictability of weather and climate
has used Lorenzo's geometry
um as uh as a kind of didactic tool but
um in the book I tried to sort of go a
bit further and um
you know address the question what if
the whole universe
evolved on some kind of fractal in some
you know humongously big
uh State space cos you know cosmological
State space the the interesting point
about that is that because there are
gaps in the fractal There Are Places no
matter where you how much you zoom in
there are places where no trajectories
ever go
my
um
what it means is that
worlds that you might conceive of in
your head
uh what we call counterfactual worlds
things that didn't happen that kind of
might have happened
may actually be inconsistent with this
geometry now what I tried to show in the
book and I've written papers on this is
that
that could this could be I'm not saying
it is it could be
a new way to understand some of the
really puzzling
sort of paradoxes and and conceptual
difficulties in quantum mechanics
paradoxically enough perhaps we could
talk about that later I don't want to
get bogged down into too much detail
yeah like kind of start with the
astonishing uh story of uh of a very you
know major character in this book I I
don't know what he looks like uh but I
think his name is uh fish Michael Fisher
oh yeah a man in the Met Office where he
used to work uh and it's uh concerns an
event that occurred uh about uh 25 years
ago almost exactly by the time the book
comes out October 16th 1987 the south of
England was battered by one of the most
brutal storms to ever hit the country in
over 300 years 15 million trees were
blown down 22 people died and damages
exceeding three billion dollars worse
yet meteorologists have predicted a nice
breezy day in the aftermath scientists
ask themselves why was the forecast so
wrong
the weather forecasters admit they got
it wrong they'd warned of a depression
approaching but they had no idea of its
strength or Direction this morning
people woke up to Devastation and four
cars like this one in the Daily
Telegraph it said the weather would have
an unsettled autumnal look
really to have predicted it further
ahead in great detail we'd have needed
more information midday yesterday the
midday run of the computer model
yesterday what we call a numerical model
which tries to simulate the atmosphere
in terms of equations that would have
needed more information at midday
yesterday when I heard about the uh the
title you know the reason for the title
coming from Feynman I actually thought
of two other uh quotes well one from him
which is uh science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts that's the first
quote I want you to react to and then
the second one is from the famous
levlando who said that cosmologists are
often in error but never in doubt
um what is the role of Doubt of doubting
yourself of being uncertain and how much
should you know people have gained or
lost confidence in Michael fish and his
ilk after failing to predict a hurricane
and instead predict taking a nice breezy
day and uh and then subsequently we'll
get into covid and on all sorts of other
predictions that are also made by our
fellow experts I mean that that's that's
scientist so how do you react to
feynman's quote science is the belief in
the ignorance of experts do you agree
with fyman
well
uh I I mean the word ignorance uh you
know
the word ignorance could indicate
a complete lack of knowledge and of
course experts don't have a complete
lack of knowledge right uh so I I I
sometimes wonder whether the word
ignorance I've come across that that
quote myself of course I do wonder
whether the word
ignorance is quite the right word to use
but
um it's certainly the case you know that
um
that someone who you know says they're
an expert on a field is fallible
um so I I you know perhaps if we could
substitute you know the fallibility of
experts for the ignorance of experts I'd
feel a bit more comfortable because
certainly uh experts are are fallible
yeah
um now you know the Michael fish storm I
I say a few words about it if you don't
mind because
um it came at a very
uh opportune time for me uh which is in
in the 19
uh 80s I had
you see again if we come back to
Lorenzo's model of Chaos
good afternoon to you earlier on today
apparently a woman rang the BBC and said
she heard that there's a hurricane on
the way well if you're watching don't
worry there isn't but having said that
actually the weather will become very
windy but most of the strong winds
incidentally will be down over Spain and
across into France as well even back in
the 1980s people knew about uh and and
of course glick's book
um popularized the notion of the
butterfly effect
so people were aware that because of
you know the flaps of butterflies Wings
causing tornadoes in Texas to occur you
know a week later or something they were
aware that the weather
you know couldn't be predicted precisely
for for long periods of time that that
was kind of fairly well accepted
but the the converse was that if you
stick to with a within a few days
uh or predicting just a few days into
the future then chaos is is not really
important and you can make uh kind of
kind of categorical predictions it will
be sunny it will be rainy it will be
stormy or it will be dry
and that pervaded the uh the
professional community of meteorologists
as well
and I used Lorenzo's model to show that
the degree of at which if you like the
degree of Chaos
uh in an initial condition really varies
a lot depending on where you are on that
fractal geometry where you are on that
stranger tractor there are some points
on the fractal attractor which are
actually extremely predictable and
stable small uncertainties don't really
affect the trajectory very much but
there are other initial conditions on
other points of the attractor which are
incredibly unstable and very very
sensitive to initial conditions and
uh so I argued that we shouldn't be
complacent about uh weather forecasting
even for a few days into the future
because if we hit one of these
exceptionally unstable points or the
atmosphere goes through one of these
very unstable points uh then we're you
know then we're in danger of making a
complete hash of the forecast
and some of my colleagues were kind of
skeptical about that or they didn't
think it was something to worry about
but the 1987 storm was just so it's so
it was a fantastic example of this very
this exactly this phenomenon that
you know the atmosphere itself is a
chaotic system but the degree of chaos
varies and can vary very substantially
from one week to the next
and we retrospectively ran an ensemble
of forecasts and by that I mean we run
we ran the weather forecast Model 50
times with very very slightly different
initial States flaps of butterflies
wings as it were introduced into the uh
initial conditions
and for this particular uh sort of retro
retrospective forecast made two days
before the storm uh hit Southern England
the spread in the Ensemble was just
extraordinarily large I mean it was just
you know bigger than you could imagine
and this was just a a clear example
as I say that chaos isn't some
kind of fixed quantity that you know
systems become unpredictable after 30
days or after whatever you want some
period of fixed period of time
it varies
um and this is this is a this is a
feature I mean this is the second if
there is if there are two themes which
run through the book
uh one is the uh the notion of
uncertainty and the other is the notion
of non-linearity
um so I pretty much all the systems I
deal with are non-linear in some way or
another
right and this notion about the degree
of predictability varying from one state
to another
is a feature of a non-linear system that
that that that really sort of almost
defines a non-linear system it sometimes
could be sometimes predictable sometimes
very unpredictable
um so the Michael fish storm uh is was
kind of Nature's Way I mean I have to
say nature came to my help uh in
persuading my colleagues that this was a
serious problem
because uh I mean you know there was
nothing else on the news for several
days the director general of the Met
Office was under a lot of pressure to
resign uh and people were just saying
how you know we spend all these millions
on the state meteorological service and
they give us such rubbish uh you know
advice or they can do uh so this really
changed the way things were done and um
now these days Ensemble forecasting is
used around the world it's pretty much
you know accepted by the current
generation and it makes a big difference
in in how you actually go about making
decisions uh we can come on to that but
one one really big area that's changed
is how humanitarian and disaster relief
organizations decide ahead of time when
to send food and medicine and water and
shelter and stuff ahead of some
predicted storm uh predicted extreme
event rather than in the old days where
they would just wait for it to happen
the hurricane to happen or whatever and
then going afterwards now they they're
going in ahead of time but they use
probabilities to make that decision
about when to go in and when not to go
and how does the you know probabilistic
or statistical
nature of uh this new method of dealing
with you know climate or weather related
issues say how does that differ for you
know how does that employ the the main
features of say chaos theory or you know
dynamical stochastic systems in other
words I I remember actually my freshman
year my my professor at Case Western
Robert Brown he used to he made us read
chaos in the physics you know course
about you know inclined planes and
mechanics and stuff we loved it
and uh he was a student of feynman's
actually at Caltech but anyway uh he you
know it was very impressive and we love
learning about you know calculating
fractal dimensions and and uh showing
you know uh the actually generating the
the butterfly or the lorenza tractor
with different exponents and uh and of
course the mandelbrot set but I never
got the sense uh that it was actually
applied in other words
um you know does my local by the way I
should say that there's um the the
extreme span of jobs exist here in San
Diego so the the hardest job in the
world is being a sportscaster uh because
we've never won a championship in any
major sport uh from uh the world series
of baseball uh to soccer to uh football
when we used to have a team but the
easiest job to compensate is
meteorologists uh because it's basically
you know they throw up a picture but
I've never heard one of them say you
know the LIE opponent of exponent of
this fractal dimension of the of the
perimeter of this approaching you know
we just had a tropical depression
Blaster here and it lasted you know
three days longer than anybody predicted
we got you know random rain and
um so do people actually use you know
the these aside from the general
features a very extreme sensitivity to
initial conditions uh aside from you
know kind of scale and variant are there
any applied ways to translate the
esoteric and beautiful mathematics of
mandelbrot and Laurent to something
practical where it would improve
something in the daily life whether it
be the price of something the impact of
something or or the uh the cause of
something so yeah can you address the
actual well you mentioned uh you you
started to mention a thing called a
lipanov exponent uh so let me let me
sort of uh uh follow up on that yeah
um because
uh in the early days
um you know we were rather sort of blase
about
uh how you would add these perturbations
to the initial conditions to generate an
ensemble
and uh it turns out that
um if you add small
small amplitude and small scale
uh perturbations into a weather forecast
model in other words you add so that a
model you know would have a
characteristic uh grid so all of the
equations are are kind of discretized
onto a grid which I mean these days is
um you know is around 10 kilometers uh
but you know go go back 30 years and
it's near 100 kilometers
um
so you you the uncertainties are largest
on the uh scales close to the grid
so you you say okay I'll just add I'll
add some sort of noise as it were to the
initial conditions
um what you find is that these
perturbations actually don't grow at all
they're completely the opposite of what
you might think from the butterfly
effect and the reason is or a key reason
anyway is that models have a lot of
artificial kind of damping and this you
know what we call artificial viscosity
to kind of keep them
uh stable and so that these kind of
small perturbations don't suddenly cause
the model to to kind of what what a
numerical analyst would call blow up do
something you know completely unphysical
um so we actually had to go about
thinking uh quite carefully about how to
construct perturbations that were
consistent with our uncertainty in the
observational Network
but we're also going to have the effect
of growing in the as the forecast ran
so you mentioned that the term leappanov
exponent and and that's a kind of a
measure of uh how
um
a a perturbation uh grows in a chaotic
system and the the largest lipanov
exponent sort of gives you the the
largest possible uh growth
so what we what we did in fact is borrow
the ideas or the techniques of Chaos
Theory to compute uh lyapanov exponents
and the associated the associated
perturbations are called the eponoff
vectors
we had to do this within the a kind of a
I don't want to go ahead and get into
technical details but finite time kind
of framework but basically we we use
these techniques from chaos theory for
computing how the uh you know how
perturbations grow uh you know and what
are the most unstable directions
essentially is what are the most
unstable directions
um perturbed along those uh rather than
just randomly perturbing so that was a
kind of an idea borrowed from chaos
theory that went right into the
um operational uh code
um but you know you're right not not
everything is and actually one thing
that's important to say and I I kind of
go into this a bit in my book
um is that there actually is a
difference between weather and let's say
lorenz's model of chaos or mandelbrot's
uh you know attractor and all this sort
of stuff which is
um and again it relates actually to
leaponov exponents which is what we
would call the dimension of the
attractor
um
so how many unstable directions are
there how many uh growingly uponov
exponents are there and for something
simple like Lorenzo's model uh there's
just a couple but for the weather
you know we think there are billions and
billions of billions I mean it's
essentially
we're dealing with in the real weather
World a very very very very large
dimensional uh chaotic system
and actually in the book I I go into the
reason why
despite the fact that the
the underlying equations that for
example the thing called The navier
Stokes equations which are equations for
fluid motion even though they're
deterministic in other words they don't
have any random
terms in the equations because we are
dealing with
a finite truncation of a system that you
know for all practical purposes actually
has an infinite number of degrees of
freedom uh it's it's actually
advantageous to add noise adds
stochastic noise you mentioned the word
stochastic there to the equations the
computational equations to represent
properly all of those kind of unstable
directions
so again uh stochasticity is something
that we've taken from the kind of more
uh say theoretical ideas in chaos theory
and applied them into operations
and when we look at the uh the
delightful figures in the book and we'll
we'll flash some of those up uh
um in the uh animated version I had the
hardcover and the uh and the ebook and
and there'll be an audiobook at some
point
um they're it's wonderfully and
beautifully Illustrated and and the
illustrations really do convey you know
the the kind of really the relevance of
this new way of thinking mathematically
that uh that you know is it's not that
new actually I mean as I said I remember
from a freshman year you know 30 years
25 years ago whatever but nevertheless
it in terms of its its applications and
what it can be useful for and of course
looming throughout the book is also the
Specter of another you know worldwide uh
event that had Global implications and
in its course of coven 19. uh which
we're still dealing with in various
incarnations I've just got over up out
of it um and I want to ask you you know
uh before we get into you know uh and
without getting into Political kind of
discussions
um because there's so much potential for
that in both the climate and covid and
economics and all sorts of other issues
in the book uh the one safe space is
when we will talk about Bell's
inequality I don't think there's any
political uh ramifications of that that
we will be tiptoeing around minefields
but what are the similarities with
something like a pandemic aside from the
fact that we had people uh you know in
both you know they're both features of
the UK or people in the UK you know
predicting dire outcomes and then
changing it I guess another Neil
Ferguson not the one who's on this
podcast a few weeks ago but uh but
another one in Imperial maybe anyway uh
what could we apply from these
additional way of thinking about
mathematical the the the the the chaos
and and attractive States and bystable
and so forth sensitivity to initial
conditions what is the relevance of that
to something that we've really known
about for you know hundreds or thousands
of years a global pandemic is there a
relevancy of this mathematical way of
thinking with these with these kind of
features that are similar to The to
Chaos Theory towards a better
comprehension of the spread of a
pandemic like coven 19.
yes
um
maybe I could just quickly uh comment on
the figure that you just quickly showed
because that illustrates also very
nicely an example of the type of kind of
intermittent chaos this one well it
wasn't that you showed us the more
planets of a planetary of a three-body
Robbie which yeah which look
um yeah I mean I I recommend anyone to
go to the actual uh online animation
because it's just phenomenal what you
see are these four bodies uh rotating
around each other in kind of what looked
to be almost well they look to be
perfect to ellipses yeah and you watch
this for a while and you say oh this is
boring I mean why am I watching this
because well and the reason you're
watching it is all of a sudden seemingly
out of nowhere uh the planets just
spiral off to Infinity it's like they
hit this it's exactly the same as the
Michael fishstorm they hit this point of
instability he having been you know
potentially for millions of years uh
just trundling around each other minding
their own business they hit this point
of instability and they suddenly zip off
to infinity and uh this is just a lovely
example of the same notion as the
Michael fishstorm
um and you know I I try to argue maybe
the the uh the um the the global
meltdown in 2008 uh could in the
financial meltdown was a was another
example of that now coming to covid
um I think what I was struck by was the
uh the the analogy in some ways is
actually better with climate change than
weather forecasting
um uh so I I have a chapter talking
about how ensembles are also used uh to
make well I gotta say the word
prediction but but perhaps that's not
the right word to use in this context
because
if you think about climate change
uh the reason we're concerned about
climate change is that we're emitting
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
they warm the planet and they change the
weather
um but the extent to which the uh
uh the extent to which the weather does
change is a function of how much we
continue to emit carbon dioxide if we
suddenly for some reason tomorrow
stopped emitting carbon dioxide then
then uh we'd be looking at a very
different climate uh by mid-century than
if we just carry on as per normal now we
can't you know I I can't I don't think
anyone can predict uh
you know what what we will decide to do
about our emissions so when you're
making
predictions of climate change they're
they're predicated on a particular
assumption about whether we'll continue
to emit as normal whether we'll cut back
a little bit or we'll cut back a lot and
so on
but we still have to use ensembles so
just having running one model with an
increase in carbon dioxide is not going
to give you a reliable uh result
um you need an ensemble which span the
uncertainties in the equations and so on
and again you essentially have
probabilistic estimates of of future
climate change now the covert thing is
is kind of similar to that in the sense
that
you know the government's governments
around the world had to make decisions
about whether to uh you know impose
lockdowns uh or you know let people just
carry on and hope for the best
um so and again those are those are not
uh you know nobody's going to be able to
predict
that so what the covert modelers do are
make in other words they use the same
words actually that that climate change
people do which is projections they're
projecting what the covert deaths and
covid hospitalizations will be uh given
certain different potential policy uh
assumptions uh yeah one policy
assumption is that uh you know nothing
we do nothing to restrict people's uh
interactions and then another one which
we restrict them a lot uh but again
because the models are imperfect models
they're particularly imperfect of course
when we're dealing with social
interactions and so on
uh then ensembles
and this was realized actually quite
quite early on I think in um in covid
modeling that
uh I mean in the case of the Imperial
College model they would put stochastic
some stochastic representations for
uncertain parameters but in the U.S they
did something which was actually much
closer to what ipcc does
for the climate change assessments which
is they they made use of the fact that
many different institutes in the US had
developed their own uh epidemiological
models and uh you know a few a few
people kind of took the lead in ensuring
that that the predictions and
projections were done in a fairly
coordinated way with you know similar
types of data output so everything could
then be analyzed in a central Hub in a
in a probabilistic way
so um
I wrote a chapter about covid because it
did strike me there was remarkable uh uh
kind of similarities in the science I
mean interestingly they're remarkable
similarities in the I mean maybe that's
less remarkable but in the political I
know you don't want to talk about
politics but the you know the people
that advocated doing you know nothing
much about climate change were typically
the same people that advocated doing
nothing much about restricting
interactions in covid so that was kind
of an interesting um parallel there but
scientifically there's a lot of a lot of
parallels between climate projections
and covert projections
yeah uh and I wonder I mean my only my
only kind of comment at the end was that
um just as uh the world the UN World
Meteorological organization pretty much
masterminded the uh the production of
these ipcc reports by by coordinating
climate modeling groups around the world
so I think perhaps the World Health
Organization could do something similar
for this type of epidemiological
modeling in other words get you know get
groups around the world to do their
uh projections in a coordinated way you
know they have the you know so you can
kind of compare and contrast them and
produce probabilistic analyzes and so on
and so forth so I hope that'll that'll
be something who taken in the book you
talk a lot about
um you know kind of a CERN for climate
change and you know I couldn't help
thinking well maybe a CERN for you know
some kind of uh Global pandemic but of
course there's a great deal of
skepticism about both of these things
some in good faith maybe some in out
without it but I mean how on a personal
level when how do you react to you know
I'm just looking at headlines from Apple
news today Wall Street Journal reports
Energy prices soaring across Europe uh
due to their Reliance and their
cancellation of nuclear energy for
example
um uh Germany gets most of its energy
now from coal after years of when
subsidies coal is reliable so it is uh
more beneficial hospitalization rates
for covet are very misleading this is in
the Atlantic uh they are coming after
the fact and they get retroactively
diagnosed according to the Atlantic now
this is not a political uh show as you
know I I believe that uh astronomy is a
safe space in cosmology and physics
because we you know no one wakes up and
says I hate that Republican
constellation over there or that Tory
that damn Tory astronaut uh asteroid
um but Tim how does that affect you when
you see you know headlines like these
that are casting doubt maybe or um maybe
it's it's where the you know scientific
becomes political
um you know what advice do you have do
we really need to invest more money to
have Global consensus and have you know
CERN cost tens of billions of dollars to
construct and tens of billions of
dollars to operate
um how would we go about convincing
somebody uh you know your new prime
minister uh to to invest in something
like a CERN for climate change what
would what would be some of the
arguments or CERN for covet
well I don't know about the Sun for
kovid because I'm perhaps not uh you
know I'm not sure I'm the right person
to talk about that but I can certainly
talk about it a certain for climate
change
um and the issue you know the issue
comes back to what I talked about
earlier which is we're dealing with a
very uh you know mathematically speaking
a very large dimensional uh chaotic
system so large Dimension means it
really needs a very large number of
variables to simulate it well uh and uh
you know a typical weather forecast
model these days would have several
billion uh variables you know
represented and you can very easily show
that
um if you skimp on that then your
hurricanes don't become as intense as
they were before or your droughts don't
become as long-lived as they were before
extreme weather you know becomes less
extreme if you start gimping on degrees
of freedom
now if you're making a 10-day weather
forecast you can pretty much run
a
um a model with a with a billion or more
degrees of freedom
on a you know a large but not
necessarily absolutely top of the range
supercomputer I mean a petaflop uh
computer would um 10 to the 15 floating
Point operations per second would would
do pretty well but when you come to
climate where we're trying to make these
projections over 50 years or so we're
trying to say what you know what's the
you know like California what's
California going to be like in the in in
um in 50 years time and you know a key
question uh which uh
you know for example a key question to
ask will be how does climate change
affect the likelihood of these La Nina
events you know because La Nina is
certainly a contributory Factor uh for
the all the um uh the droughts and the
and and the fires and things that you've
had so
um it becomes a complex question and uh
I very much am of the view that the sort
of computing capabilities that a
university group would have or you know
a typical uh you know National Institute
you mentioned the the San Diego Scripps
uh oceanographic Institute World leading
Institute but it doesn't have the
compute power to do this type of
calculation and I would you know what by
concern for climate change what I'm
really arguing for is is dedicated
absolute top of the range super
Computing which these days is exascale
10 to the 18 flops per second floating
Point operations per second dedicated to
climate change and that's not happening
at the moment anywhere around the world
uh but a kind of an international
Consortium it it actually we're not
talking about billions we're talking
about maybe one to two hundred million a
year so it's not a big deal it's uh you
know it's a it's a it's a satellite
program or something like that I don't
know
um uh so for me it's kind of a
no-brainer
um it comes you know if if I'm talking
to a climate skeptic
I would say look you
surely are as interested as I am or as a
climate you know somebody that's very
concerned about climate change to know
the truth you know how bad is it going
to get yeah
um this is the only way we have to solve
this problem Computing uh or solving the
laws of physics
is the only way we have to deal with
this we can answer this question there's
no laboratory experiment we can do to
emulate climate change isn't it is it
right yeah is it even possible though I
mean I've you know you make a very very
clear distinction in the book between
things that are complex systems and
things that are merely complicated you
know I always say like building uh a 787
you know jetliner is incredibly
complicated it's hard to do it could
take an individual you know a billion
years to do it but if he or she follows
the instructions has the raw materials
puts them into parts and etc etc it can
be done on the other hand you know it
seems to me the smallest possible and
and you should um Define for my audience
the various definitions of complexity so
forth but the smallest possible system
that's capable of modeling global
climate and or even weather is the
climate itself in other words it's kind
of an old school analog computer uh and
on fortunately you get the results after
the event but there's there's no letter
from God that says you have to be able
to predict things in the future right so
um what do you make of the uh of of the
fact that perhaps it's not just mere
computing power and I'm saying Mir I
don't mean to denigrate at all and I
think it's it's absolutely necessary but
maybe that's not enough and and you know
uh is it could it be the situation
requires you know a literal global scale
computer not just a global collaboration
of computing power
well let me let me just say look I mean
why are we trying to do this in the
first place and I would say perhaps
the number one uh reason is that
countries around the world now are
having to face the fact that climate
change is a reality
um and part of the uh spending is going
to be on how to make Society more
resilient how to adapt to climate change
you know the climate change that's
already gonna going to happen
um
uh you know Pakistan great example I
mean what what do they do if these
things are going to hit these floods
that we've had in the last couple of
weeks going to hit them every few years
now with kind of unbelievable intensity
how is that country going to adapt to
climate change
um
but there's a sort of subtle question uh
actually even taking Pakistan uh in in
mind because
at the moment we're kind of in a
a very much a sort of transition phase
where the weather patterns are staying
pretty much as they are but the
temperatures getting warmer you know the
air holds more water so when it rains it
rains more
but in the next couple of decades what
we're going to start to see are more
dynamical effects so the the the
circulation patterns are going to start
to change
um and and this is really a key question
then if you're adapting to climate
change if you're uh you know a country
in Africa or you know southeast Asia you
have to decide is my greater threat uh
drought and heat wave or is it storm
uh and flooding and uh storm surge and
that sort of thing and very different
types of expenditure are gonna you know
you're gonna you're gonna spend money on
completely different things if you think
the main threat is from droughts and
heat waves or if you think it's from
storms and floods
so we absolutely need this information
and uh as you say you we can wait for it
to happen uh that's the kind of analog
if you like but but and the problem is
um you know again I mentioned this in
the book that
you know one of the
you know at the turn of this Millennium
uh the the clay Mathematics Institute uh
announced the the most important
mathematical problems that faced uh the
mathematical world at the turn of the
millenniums kind of mirroring what David
Hilbert did in 1900 announcing what were
then the key problems and um the the
Millennium prob one of the Millennium
Problems was actually about the navier
Stokes equations
and you could interpret this problem as
implying that we don't have a kind of
uber Theory
which will tell us if you get your model
grid down to one kilometer say you will
simulate the climate with you know an
accuracy of of 95 or something like that
I I mean I just wish we could do that
because then I could go to the
politicians and bang my fist on the
table and say look I have a I can prove
mathematically if you give me 100
million year I will you know simulate
climate to 95 accuracy and I can't do
that
um but all common sense and all
experience in weather forecasting or
much shorter time scales tells us that
as we increase the resolution of these
we reduce the size of these grids which
means we increase the resolution of the
models
um which means we're solving these
equations more accurately then we then
we simulate things better we get
extremes better we get all these things
better so all the you know all the all
the uh kind of evidence is pointing to a
kind of a modest investment in a in
um you know one or or a few
International institutes that can put
dedicated exoscale Computing to get us
down to kilometer scale grids is going
to make a big change and it seems much
more models which are pretty inaccurate
at the moment I have to say on the
regional scale you know I I you know I I
don't know whether your listeners will
want to know this fact but if you
if you are the this country uh in Africa
or or southeast Asia that I mentioned
and you look up the ipcc uh figure the
figure in the ipcc report for how
uh rainfall is going to change is it
going to get wetter in your country or
drier in your country you'd think that
was a pretty basic question that
everyone would want to know is it going
to get wetter or is it going to get
drier
for pretty much you know most of the
globe uh the models just don't agree
there'll be this little cross-hatched
region of the duck figure and you
consult The Legend and it says cross
hatching means the models don't agree so
this is a a pretty unsatisfactory I
would say State of Affairs and um it's
coming because well it's coming because
we we parametrize all these processes
which are important because we don't
have the Computing to solve the
equations exactly and the
parametrizations are exceptionally uh
uncertain and it seems to me that you
know governments are willing to spend
you know enormous amounts of money we
just had a bill in America you know good
fraction of a trillion dollars and and
uh the anal analysis that I've seen from
independent organizations it'll reduce
temperatures global temperatures by less
than a tenth of a degree Fahrenheit and
uh by the end of the century and um you
know whereas for as you say you know
literally a thousandth of that amount of
money you could have you know exascale
computers dedicated to this
um well and yet I still wonder you know
because kova does play a role in the
book and and your thought process um you
know I remember back in January 2020
had been invited to go to uh to China to
speak in Tibet of all places where
they're building a CMB Observatory and
they wanted to have show it to me and I
thought oh that's great and I got
excited I've never been to China and I
asked uh I was at dinner at a Friday
night Shabbat dinner and one of my
friends had here in San Diego
and uh one of my friends told me he's
been to China many times and he's like I
don't think you should go there you know
this is early mid-January uh you know
because there's this covid-19 and I I
had heard about it but I was like you
know I've heard all these things in SARS
and this thing yeah okay hopefully by
April it'll be resolved of 2020. I mean
it is January after all the invitation
it's like uh look a little bit closer
needless to say it wasn't resolved and
it might not even still be resolved some
parts of China are locked down in the
end of 2022.
um but given that we in the US at least
and I assume in other countries as well
we have you know Trill multi-trillion
dollars worth of three letter agencies
you know from the NSA and and the FBI
and the CI we have all these spy
agencies all these
um and they didn't even get you know the
fact that we should order 10 cent masks
for everybody or you know that we should
start working on stuff and not all of
that was you know because of who is the
president or who controlled Congress I
think it was a failure of these huge you
know sclerotic organizations to
translate their discoveries or maybe
they didn't know and and that terrifies
me more if you pay somebody a trillion
dollars the very damn least they better
know is that well you know China just
built this Hospital in eight days that
can hold ten thousand people well why
would they do that you know I mean
forget about the micro or you know
biology of the organism just a practical
on the ground fast we didn't do any of
that and my friend knew that all of that
in January of 2020 he's not like some
spy for the government so you know I
guess the question I always have is is
how do we translate you know politicians
are very quick as you know to clamor for
you know their particular scientific
findings uh if it agrees with their
persuasion politically
um but how do we actually get them to
listen to people like you and your
colleagues to say look no we don't need
to to like you know Outlaw uh gas
powered cars in in America uh you know
in 20 20 35 what we we need is 200
million dollars a year for 10 years to
get better forecasting so that we can
adapt as humans are much better at
adapting than we are predicting so how
do we how do you bridge that Gap I mean
you have a share of a Nobel Prize which
is uh sitting in your office there uh
how do we get them to listen not just
the science that furthers their
political goals but to listen to the
true signs the good signs that you and
your colleagues are doing
uh
I mean it's it's it's a tough it's a
tough
problem I mean as you know uh
as a scientist you know I can't make
decisions and I in a way you know I all
I can do as a scientist is is lay out
the science as clearly
uh as possible and uh uh and we just
have to hope that the the politicians
get it I mean the politicians did get it
eventually at least here in the UK they
did get it with covid although you know
they were very slow on the uptake uh I
think the science
of course to the science was pretty
uncertain in the initial phase because
we would I mean this covid was a was an
unusual I mean the thing that made it
difficult was the fact that a lot of
people
were asymptomatic they were carrying it
and they could spread it but they didn't
really have this you know the symptoms
themselves so unlike normal
uh or more kind of uh familiar types of
of diseases you know where you get ill
and there you automatically go to bed
and you isolate this was one where lots
of people were getting uh getting the
covert virus that weren't symptomatic of
of of having problems so uh so so you
know there was a lot of challenges for
for the science in the early phase but I
think in this case the politicians
uh at least here in the UK they did they
did get it we had we had a lot of
committees and things but
I mean
very active in at the moment trying to
you know sell this CERN for climate
change idea
um I have to say one of the frustrations
is that
some maybe maybe this was like the real
CERN back in the 50s I don't know but
some of my colleagues
I think you know they are nervous that
if a new Institute was uh funded the
money would come from their institute's
budget so they might you know let's say
uh we're talking about San Diego uh you
know if the US decided to go down this
route
um would you know would the Scripps
Institute find that it's budget you know
was was being paired off a little bit to
help pay for this and that that creates
some uh I would say uh kind of uh
nervousness amongst some of the uh
community and and this is a problem
because when I talk to
you know the really big scientific
advisors in the UK
I mean a question they immediately asked
me do does your community speak with one
voice
and I would say well you know there are
some people who and they would stop me
mid-sentence and they would say come
back where they speak with one voice
that's never gonna happen and that that
so that that's that's an issue uh which
uh you know uh which
uh which we're trying to kind of get get
over uh trying to kind of convince the
arc friends that
because we'll still need the kind of
what I would call the conventional
models
you know there's loads of uh of really
important climate work for example
understanding paleo climate variations I
mean that that you know that involves
running models for thousands tens of
thousands of years there's no way we're
going to be able to run a one kilometer
model over ten thousand years it's
inconceivable so we'll need low we'll
need lower resolution models for doing
you know some of the basic science and
some of the Paleo climate work and
things like that so I don't think these
people actually should feel concerned
that they're somehow their their pet
models are being somehow uh made
redundant uh it's just we'll need a
hierarchy and and for the really
important
uh kind of climate policy stuff
um
uh like next week I'm going on a
committee this is another example
um about this climate geoengineering
should we be spraying uh aerosols in
Stratosphere yeah
and I would say how would you ever make
that decision if you had models that had
you know biases and systematic errors
that were as large as the signals that
you're trying to simulate with this
thing is it's just it doesn't just
doesn't seem plausible that we'd ever
sanctions such a a plan B without having
a very good idea for example whether the
monsoons were going to shut off or the
moisture Supply into the rainforest was
going to shut off and we're not going to
do that unless we have models that can
really get these Regional details
uh you know done correct correctly and
accurately so I I think there's plenty
of I mean I hope there's there's enough
you know this is such an important
problem
there's enough space here for a
hierarchy of models from the very simple
lorentz chaos model through to these
kind of 100 kilometer scale climate
models which you would use for Paleo
work through to the one kilometer models
which are going to inform
policy for the next 50 years or so there
must be there must be room for all of us
surely
so I want to transition
um uh for the the second half of the
conversation into a um into more
speculative ideas perhaps but maybe not
and I couldn't escape you know thinking
about the connection between quantum
mechanics and interpretation and
foundations of quantum mechanics which
are quite quite you know popular and and
have you know been receiving a lot of
attention lately many books written
about it but also I think yours is the
first book to really attempt to make a
connection between you know as I have in
my notes here between the butterfly and
the bell you know Bell being Bell's
inequality right so I wonder first of
all if you can um you know if you if you
don't mind uh kind of recapitulating uh
what is Bell's theorem what is what is
real if you don't mind in in a few
minutes uh what what is that nature of
Belle's inequality a lot of people hear
it we've done interviews Adam Becker
wrote a book called what is real about
it uh but but a lot of people people you
know kind of what's a big deal you know
if I go into my sock drawer and I've got
a pair of red socks and a pair of white
socks and I go on a on a holiday let's
open up my suitcase and I've got a pair
that's a red sock and a white sock I
know for damn sure in my drawer at home
there's a white sock and a red sock too
uh so what is this about the we should
have Sabina here
um you know to actually quote uh to
quote the exact term that Einstein used
your Manchester Washington first uh I
don't know I do know that she said that
this book your book is a whirlwind it's
partly scientific autobiography and
partly a Manifesto of a Visionary Tim
Palmer masterly weaves through climate
change quantum mechanics into one
coherent whole he is a revolutionary
thinker way ahead of his time so let's
weave together the butterfly and the
bell jar uh yeah what is the Bell
inequality what does it tell us what is
it important is it just kind of a
mathematical audit well let's let's
start with the butterfly because because
the butterfly effect is is a pretty
um
it kind of conforms I think to what most
of us think of as uncertainty
um the idea being that you know we can't
uh you know clearly we can't observe all
of the butterflies in the world that
flap their wings correct
um I mean the butterflies themselves
can see their wings flapping uh they're
not at all uncertain about the fact
they're flapping their wings but we
humans can't see all of that so
really what the butterfly effect is
saying is that the uncertainty in a
weather forecast
comes because we don't have perfect
information about you know the starting
conditions for the weather forecasts so
a philosopher would call that epistemic
or epistemological uncertainty it's a
kind of a lack of knowledge about the
system that you're interested in yes and
that kind of characterizes I would say
most you know most things in life that
we we don't know things because we can't
know everything about the system that
we're interested in
um
and of course you know Einstein that
that's kind of how Einstein felt Quantum
uncertainty should be too it's
reflecting something that we don't know
about the electrons or the photons you
know that's kind of going on at a
smaller level than we can possibly see
but Bell's theorem Bell's inequality or
the Belgium whatever you want to call it
um is probably the single most important
uh expert well it's a theoretical result
but has been tested experimentally which
I think most probably most physicists
would say uh
uh kind of really I was gonna say cast
out but that's too weak a phrase most
visitors would say it disproves
Einstein's view right
um and bait so so basically the as you
say uh it's kind of based on it's based
on an idea or a word which which
schrodigger came up with uh when he
actually when he was at Oxford
um which is this notion that Quantum
systems can be entangled and
um
and as you say that that gives rise to
correlations you know you you could say
it's a bit like a you know two particles
go off and one's got a red sock and
one's got a white sock or something so
if You observe the red sock you know the
other one is certainly the white sock
except that it's not like that because
what Bell so Belle was an Irish
physicist who worked at CERN
and he realized that if that was what
was behind this entanglement that you
know one electron had a red sock on and
if you measured the red sock you could
determine that the other electron going
in the other direction had a white sock
if that was all there was to it
then Bell
uh
Bell realize that these you could you
could look at these correlations
uh I mean basically it kind of basically
it's about measuring the spin of
particles or the polarization of photons
um and you measure them in in different
ways and the correlations
uh you you know the result is a
mathematical one where you sum up these
correlations
and uh if
if uncertainty really was
the fact that you uh you know we didn't
know whether the electron was wearing
its its red sock or it's white sock if
that's what it was then this
kind of sum of correlations that Bell
came up with would be uh would would
have a largest value a value of two
um so sum correlations done with
different measuring uh different
polarizers and you come up with this
thing which says if if if everything is
deterministic and the uncertainty is
just due to the fact that we don't know
everything about the electron or the
photon then this this uh correlation
function summing over over correlations
from different experiments is kind of
bounded by the number two
and you do the experiment and you find
for certain uh settings of these
polarizers this number exceeds two
so there's something gone wrong with
your assumptions
and most physicists would say that the
assumption that goes wrong is that
uncertainty is epistemological and that
really what's happening is that the
equations of quantum mechanics are
intrinsically uncertain it's not like
it's like the butterflies they're all
the electrons if the electrons are the
equivalent to the butterflies the
electrons don't know what they're doing
the electrons are uncertain
um and since quantum mechanics is a
theory of everything you know it's
describing the world it's believed at
least to be a theory describing
everything in the world then everything
in the world of some sense including
reality is uncertain and that is the
sort of I would say the sort of standard
View
now there is there's there's another
there's another way around it but it's
kind of it's kind of I mean it's kind of
just as bad which is to say that
when you measure the electron and you
see it's got a white uh sock that
somehow
uh makes the electron on the other side
of the experiment have a red sock so
prior to you actually doing that
measurement the the the electron sort of
had neither a white circle or a red sock
but doing a measurement on one one
particle
somehow instantaneously makes the other
particle have something definite now
that again you know Einstein didn't like
that quite rightly he called it spooky
action at a distance the idea that doing
something here can instantaneously
change something over there
so we're kind of left with I think a
very unsatisfactory State of Affairs but
the consensus view I would say amongst
the majority of physicists who think
about this problem is that uncertainty
in quantum mechanics is so the buzzword
would be ontological rather than
epistemological ontological meaning it's
kind of the notion of reality is
uncertain yeah
well okay I kind of came into this many
years ago kind of feeling good this this
can't be right surely and looking very
very carefully
uh at Bell serum again and from the sort
of perspective of my uh kind of chaos
background and this is what I like to
think I'm bringing something
which may be the standard Quantum
Community haven't quite sort of seen in
in this way
which we spoke a little bit about
earlier
um which is this notion that when you
when you go through Bell serum carefully
you imagine a particle and you imagine
an experimenter doing an experiment on a
particle
but to prove the Bell inequality you
have to assume that had the experimenter
done a different measurement to the one
he or she actually did
then they would have got some definite
result and this is sometimes called
counterfactual definiteness and you know
in life we tend to I mean we all use
kind of counterfactual reasoning to some
extent oh God if only I had
done this and not done that you know
life would be so much better now we kind
of assume that it makes sense to talk
about these counterfactual worlds
but I I try to argue from the point of
view of Chaos Theory it's not a it's not
a given that a counter factual world uh
is consistent with the laws of physics
and we talked earlier about these
fractal attractors with their gaps in
them
and if you're counterfactual world ended
up in one of these gaps that would tell
you
and and the states of your system had to
lie on the fractal then that's telling
you that counterfactual that you've just
thought up is actually inconsistent with
this geometry so the short answer is I
personally think and I have to say I'm
saying this
uh without
you know probably if you polled an
average physicist they they might say
well he's he maybe it's interesting but
I don't sure I believe it at the moment
so it's this is a controversial point of
view but I think there is a way around
the Bell theorem which doesn't require
you to give up
on this notion of a definite reality or
or have to invoke this spooky action at
a distance and that's actually why I
wrote a paper with Sabina hosenfelder
because it comes under the uh what some
people call the super determinism which
is not a word I'm terribly keen on but
um
if it if it is the case that
counterfactual reasoning can sometimes
fail you in quantum mechanics and I as I
say I think it can do for perfectly
rational and sensible reasons
um then your model is is a is belongs to
this class of super deterministic models
and I I think that is a much more
plausible uh way to understand
Quantum uncertainty and and it really
what it does then is it brings you back
to what I think both Einstein and
Schrodinger would have been much more
happy with
and others as well direct was pretty
unhappy with quantum mechanics uh which
is to say that Quantum uncertainty is
actually epistemic and it's not
ontological the laws of physics at their
deepest I think are certain and definite
and that uncertainty ultimately is our
uncertainty and what about the person
practicing the epistemology or the
ontology in other words what about the
role of Consciousness as you know your
fellow axonian who uh endorsed this book
wholeheartedly uh saying the very
delightful uh praise that Tim Palmer's
book The Primacy of Doubt provides a
remarkably broad ranging account of
uncertainty in physics in all its
various aspects I strongly recommend
this highly thought-provoking book as
you know Roger's been on the show many
times and this good friend
um and uh he and Stuart hammeroff were
on a month or so ago on the occasion of
Sir Roger's 91st birthday now we
celebrate his 90th birthday last year uh
and when we uh when we discussed it we
we got into kind of Notions of quantum
mechanics in the brain and and we also
explored I asked him to steal man uh the
many worlds interpretation which you
know he doesn't believe in
um and you know what if any role that
has on uh or could play in what he calls
orchestrated or objective reality now
you have this collapse
um that is caused as my limited
understanding has it you know from some
gravitational interactions involving uh
space-time curvature
um you've written a lot about uh his uh
conformal cyclic cosmology we'll maybe
finish up with that in a little bit but
when we talk about uh the brain and
quantum mechanics
um and determinism what role does the
Observer play in your notion of or what
you believe to be uh this sort of you
know maybe drastically and noisy brain
that that you've also had a recent paper
about and you talk about in the book so
first of all noise in Quantum systems in
in biological systems what is the role
and is it merely adding as you said you
know viscosity artificial viscosity some
things converge and don't blow up or is
it really a manifestation of Nature and
turbulence and so forth is a feature of
the brain and the noise they're in needs
to be comprehended as well before we
even get to a Quantum understanding of
Consciousness what is the role of noise
in Consciousness if any right right
um can I just start with one point you
make because you mentioned the word
collapse yeah collapse of the wave
function
um uh so uh in the model which I
propose
um there is no collapse of the wave
function because the wave function is
representing an ensemble of of States on
this uh on this fractal attractor so
what I what what a Quantum uh theorist
would call measurement is actually
um you know it's like
ball bearings going into one of two
basins of Attraction you know uh uh and
some of them will cluster in one Basin
and another and another set of ball
bearings will cluster in a different
Basin and basically that is what I see
as measurement it's actually the it's
where non-linearity starts to affect the
quantum World
um and it's clustering trajectories in
discrete uh clusters now the human I
think Consciousness doesn't and I think
Roger would agree with this actually
Consciousness doesn't play any role at
all in creating
uh in doing in doing Quantum measurement
but where I would sort of take perhaps
some departure from Roger is that I
don't think
uh there is any collapse at all of the
wave function it's just a kind of
transition
from a a very sort of I have a I have a
particular geometric model where you
have trajectories in a like a helix and
they're kind of rotating like a piece of
rope they kind of they classic they
rotate around each other
and their measurement is a kind of
splaying of the ends of the rope and
bits of the Rope go into one cluster of
states and and other bits of rope go
into another cluster of state and these
would be called the measurement outcomes
now uh so so that that's just on that
but on Consciousness and noise so there
is actually an interesting uh kind of
story which is that um
I I've been trying to promote the idea I
think I mentioned earlier in our talk
that there is a good reason to add noise
to a climate model uh to represent the
degrees of freedom you can't uh simulate
explicitly and you can show that adding
noise actually does help improve uh the
the some aspects of the climatology of
the model and I I in the book in the
book I have old chapter where I
again this is another area where
non-linearity plays an important role in
a non-linear system noise can be your
friend it's not your enemy
um you know typically we think of of
noise as a nuisance that we try to kind
of minimize but in a non-linear system
noise can actually help amplify a signal
and I've given several examples in the
in the book of how that can happen now
I've so I've been arguing for some years
now that noise in climate models is a
good thing
um and I think probably most people
would agree with that now but still to
this day we generate the Noise by uh you
know something I think that Von Neumann
originally started with which is what's
called a pseudo-random number generator
in other words it's a piece of code
which is perfectly deterministic but it
kind of emulates randomness
and of course you know it takes a
certain amount of of computational
energy to run a pseudo-random number
generator
so why not make use of noise in Hardware
so you know we've got all this noise of
the electrons going through the uh
through the chips uh and so on and I a
colleague of mine Krishna Palam has
pioneered this notion
of
uh or producing kind of noisy uh chips
where you turn the voltage down across
the transistors so they no longer act as
completely bit reproducible
deterministic systems
the point is with that is you can then
produce noise with negative energy costs
because you've turned the voltage down
you're using less energy than you did
before
so when I proposed this I had a kind of
commentary in nature proposing that our
supercomputers you know should have
cabinets some of the cabinets not all of
them of course but some of them should
be deliberately stochastic where we
would run uh we would you know we turn
the voltage down across the transistors
we'd be using less energy so there'd be
kind of noisy computationally
uh and people thought this was a bit of
a weird idea so I I had to try and think
of an example where uh you know in
reality the system does do this and I
think the brain is a good example of
this so the brain
you know the brain does phenomenal
amounts of data processing uh on 20
watts of energy it's typically six
orders of magnitude less than a
supercomputer does uses which is more
like 20 megawatts of energy but for the
same amount of data processing
so
um so so what's going on here with 20
watts well we've developed these
incredibly uh you know slender neurons
with with very small diameters 0.1
microns or whatever
uh and as a result of that we've managed
to cram 80 odd billion neurons into our
brain
so when you calculate uh how much
um
if you like energy or power there is per
neuron I mean it's just a microscopic
amount and the question is
is it possible that
um
the transition transmission rather of of
electrical energy along axons is
actually susceptible to noise and the
evidence all the evidence is for these
very slender neurons that axons that are
in the human brain
they are susceptible to noise
okay so is that a bad thing or a good
thing and in the book I try to argue
it's a good thing and it's probably
what's made us the kind of creative
species we are and it's interesting you
talk about I mean Roger Penrose is a
great example of a phenomenon which is
pretty much Universal I think amongst
you know people have had Eureka moments
because their Eureka moment doesn't
happen when they're you know hard at
work thinking about the problem they're
trying to solve it it happens in a
completely
uh kind of at a time when you're you're
multitasking when the brain all the
neurons in the brain are doing different
things and in Roger's case he was
crossing the road he was talking to a
colleague of his he was looking out for
traffic you know and then suddenly this
idea which turned out to be the thing
that got in the Nobel Prize about how to
define an event horizon in a in a kind
of generic way
um came to him and this is very common
that people who have when they have
their brilliant ideas it's when they're
relaxing or just you know doing nothing
in particular and I think this is where
uh the brain where noise in the brain is
most likely to have its biggest effect
when we're when we're multitasking we're
we're looking around us we're hearing
things we're walking down the road we're
perhaps talking to a colleague
then suddenly out of nowhere we'll get
some idea now of course we have to then
analyze whether that crazy idea is uh is
any any good or not and nine times out
of ten or maybe 99 000 or 100 it's not
much good I mean Michael Berry the
theoretical physicist at Bristol has a
great expression for this he he talks
about these ideas that come out out of
your subconsciousness as claritons
like a particle but he says the problem
with claritons is that in the cold light
of day The Logical analysis uh which he
calls an anti-claraton uh destroys the
claritol in a particle anti-particle
Annihilation
um but it kind of makes the point that
um you know actually there are two parts
to this one is the just the the
randomness of having these ideas and
then the other is the fact that we have
uh a kind of a more deterministic side
to our analytical processing which kind
of then decides whether the idea is any
good or not and it's this two it's the
Synergy between the the randomness and
the determinism that probably is what
makes us
uh the creative species we are so anyway
the point is I think that noise
uh plays a a really important role in
human creativity and we'd not be the
species we are if if our neurons were
more deterministic so so that kind of
provides a good example of why having
noisy Hardware you know might be a good
thing and I I would definitely think
that you know for improving AI or the
prospects of AI being really intelligent
uh we we probably need to go down that
route yeah well you brought it up so I
can't help but but but uh you know kind
of use one of my favorite examples which
you probably know uh doing your PhD with
Dennis schama who's a Titan of 20th
century uh physics and cosmology but um
but do you remember what Einstein called
his happiest thought Tim this here's
Einstein here
[Laughter]
I do but it slips my mind so he said
I'll give you a hint to him here you go
here's the hint
oh what falling in the elevator yes
that's right that's right
um that's right I mean you know
I'd love to know where he thought that
do you do you know where did he have
that I don't but bringing on your work
uh I bet it was in the bath or yeah
maybe playing the violin or something
but yeah exactly irrelevant to your
statement that you know Ai and you know
the the we'll have to incorporate some
of these features you often hear that
you know Einstein or sorry that you know
AI is going to be capable of reproducing
The Works of you know the greatest Minds
in science and and even going Beyond
them but that statement has always kind
of been a counter factual piece of
evidence against those claims that
Einstein said my happiest thought a how
can a computer have a notion of what
makes it happy
um or two uh how could such an uh a
Computing device have a uh have a notion
of what Free Fall is uh I have a
Computing device here
um you know in in my uh I can make it do
certain things like computer turn off
the lights turn off the plug computer
turn off the plug
there we go so it'll do stuff for me it
won't unplug itself though Tim I I try
to get it to do that and it wouldn't do
that and it won't I'll open the pod bay
doors either I've tried it sounds a bit
uh let's try that with uh with Sean
Carroll it didn't work
um so what how optimistic should we be
you talk about Quantum Computing in the
book is that potential uh you know uh
Boone for for other top topics of of uh
foundations and quantum mechanics or or
or or in predicting the weather or
something like that will we have well I
I mean we're getting on to a big we're
getting into a big era here I'm I'm you
know I'm um
if we want to talk about Quantum
Computing okay I've just written the
paper which I'm submitting to the
bulletin of the American Meteorological
Society about whether quantum computers
will ever be used for weather and
climate prediction wow and I've called
it The Good The Bad and The Noisy
because you know there are good points
um
and the the good point is that you know
uh I mentioned about billions of degrees
of freedom but you know you don't have
to have that many qubits which are fully
entangled before you have billions of
degrees of freedom so 30 I think 30 or
something 2 to the power 30 would give
you roughly that sort of thing so so
from that point of view uh it's it's
kind of looks good but there's a big
negative which is that at the end of the
day you have to measure these these 30
qubits and it's a bit like a you know
it's it's it's like saying instead of uh
you know with a weather forecast model
now you just say you know print out the
temperature
uh you know in the US and you'll get
values for temperature at different
places and stuff like that or rainfall
with a quantum computer you have to say
is it raining in New York you have to
ask it a question that it will just
answer yes or no and you've only got 30
of these questions to ask you know is it
rainy in New York is it snowing in uh
Cape Town is it sunny in London uh and
soon the computer say I'm sorry you run
out of questions that's it and that's
absolutely hopeless you know because the
amount of data that people need
across all the different applications
you know is more than just 30 questions
so that for me is a it is something you
don't see discussed very often that you
know there's the upside to the
exponential size of Hilbert spaces that
you can simulate systems with relatively
few qubits
um with very large degrees of freedom
the downside is you better not want to
know very much about your system because
at the end of the day all you can do is
measure those 30 qubits and that's just
too much of a restriction you know it's
like saying it's like saying if all I
ever cared about was how much the the
global temperature is going to increase
if all I care about is going to be two
degrees warmer or four degrees warmer
because of climate change okay fine but
as soon as you ask questions about is it
going to rain in London is it going to
be you know hotter or drier in
Mozambique or something then it's all
bets are off it's completely hopeless
so that's uh that's one thing the other
thing I would say about AI is that AI is
fantastic for interpolating but pretty
hopeless for extrapolating and the
problem with climate change is it's a
problem in extrapolation uh you can't
just take a look at past data and say I
know what's going to happen in 50 years
time even if you've got a super clever
AI system and you know uh so again I
think there are there's there's a role
for AI there's probably a role for
Quantum but it's not a Panacea
absolutely not
well Tim this has been phenomenally uh
entertaining and elucidating educational
for me and I noticed for my audience as
well and you've been so gracious with
your time I just want to beg your
forbearance for a few more minutes if
you wouldn't mind indulging me and going
into the impossible with my fantastic
final four questions that I like to ask
my guests is that okay with you sir
right
okay so uh the first question they'll
involve in some way around your late
country mints or Arthur C Clarke but um
the first one involves
um your near-term future although I hope
it won't be for 50 years or more and
that involves what we call an ethical
will and even Alfred Nobel had an
ethical will in his otherwise ethical
component of his otherwise material will
in that the Nobel Prize was to be given
to those who conferred the greatest
benefit to mankind
uh and in that sense he wasn't just
leaving money but he wanted to agitate
towards the Improvement of humanity
I want to ask you in
50 60 years when you spring forth the
Mortal coil that the immortal Bard spoke
about uh what kind of wisdom not just
knowledge but what kind of wisdom would
you want to give over to the to the
succeeding generations to come
[Music]
um
well look I tell you one thing that uh I
feel privileged as a scientist and I'm
sure Brian you you you're probably the
same as me that you know we we work in
our own different fields but science is
very International
and uh you get to talk to people you
know from completely different cultures
and completely different countries
um and the one thing you realize very
quickly when you do that is that we all
have the same problems you know we all
have things which we're frustrated about
in life
uh you know uh getting the right kind of
you know professional recognition uh
having to earn enough money to keep our
families going and you know all the sort
of stuff you know it's kind of universal
and
you realize I mean you know I
you know I worked for many years at a
European meteorological Institute which
had you know people from every country
in Europe and you know we we joke about
you know you can joke about National
stereotypes you know the Brits of
pompous
so-and-so's and they have no taste in
food decent food and you know the
Americans not the Americans but uh the
Germans yeah and I won't say anything
about the American the Germans have no
sense of humor that sort of thing so we
can make jokes about that but what you
actually realize is that the
the differences between individuals is
much you know even within a single uh
culture is much much
bigger than any kind of national
stereotypical difference oh yeah and I
think you know if I had to it's not
exactly a word of wisdom but
it just bothers me these days and I I
guess I'm kind of slightly
I've got bothered by in my own country
with brexit the fact that we're we're
sort of we seem to be
moving away from our European partners
and things more and more that
we're all basically the same we're all
got the same issues the same problems
and if you know
there you can find a brick that's got a
good sense of humor and you can find a
brick that's got no sense of humor and
that difference is is infinitely larger
than any kind of national stereotype
between the Brits and the Germans or
whatever it is so it's really
recognizing if I had a piece of wisdom
that science has given me because
science is so International
is that you know we're all basically the
same and uh We've you know the more we
can uh and we're the same on this in
this infinitesimally small planet that's
going around the vast Universe the more
we can kind of come to terms with that I
think the better we'll we'll get on as a
human species and it's beautiful
uh so you may know that uh Arthur C
Clarke is famous for many pithy
aphorisms we'll get into some of them
but uh one of them was any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic we actually open the audio
version of each podcast with his actual
voice and just a reminder you guys can
follow uh the podcast and video and on
audio Dr Brian Keating on YouTube uh and
uh also on audio wherever you get your
your podcast and this will be available
on publication day for this wonderful
new book but I want to ask you uh kind
of in reference to Arthur's you know
2001 the Space Odyssey the Sentinels
these weird kind of obelisks or
monoliths that appear throughout the
movie uh we don't really know what they
are maybe a time capsule uh and uh could
be a warning uh about uh about the
future but if you had access to a time
capsule and you knew it would last a
billion years what would you put on it
or in it you know now we're going deep
into to the Future well beyond your
120th year on the planet
um
[Music]
well I think I think I would
so I gotta say something mathematical
and I would um I'll explain what it
means you you'll know what it means uh I
I would write the equation it's not
really an equation but I'd write the uh
uh sort of a sort of mathematical
equation which would say SO2
uh equals sorry s u 2 s u 2 equals SO3
three and underneath it I would say
we know it's true but we don't
understand why it's true
and you know I think one of one of the
quotes I can't quote it exactly
um from one of the greatest uh
mathematicians of the 20th century uh
Michael attia who who worked a lot with
Roger Penrose yeah
he kind of made this point that su2 is a
is a mathematical term for a a group
based on complex numbers so these are
numbers you know based on the square
root of minus one
and SO3 is a group which is about how
you can rotate objects in physical space
and they maintain their symmetry like a
sphere you can rotate and it's still a
sphere
now these two are related
but you know Atia himself so don't you
know I'm just getting this from him he's
one of the greatest mathem he was one of
the greatest mathematicians he said
that the complex numbers are somehow the
square root of geometry but we just
don't know really what it means and I my
kind of all my gut instinct is that if
we had to understand something
uh that would take us further deeper
into fundamental physics it's really
understanding what this relationship
really really really means and so I kind
of put that in my time capsule because I
hope
the in a million years they would say
aha he was right he was right to
understand he was right to question that
because we've only understood it 10
years ago and and it's really opened the
door to quantum gravity and the Mystery
of the Universe and everything yeah so
I'd love to talk a bit more about that
but and if I if I write another popular
book I'm thinking I might actually that
might be a kind of a theme of it because
I feel it's really really something
that's important that we just don't
quite understand what it's saying yeah
that is fascinating yeah let me in my
time capsule I've always been fascinated
by this uh operation that you can do in
classical mechanics which is the form of
poisson bracket and you do the exact
same thing in a quantum mechanical
setting you make a poisson bracket and
what you get zero in the classical uh uh
commutation anti-commutation relations
and you get you know you get the square
root of negative one and this funny
constant you know Planck's constantly
emerges and all leave I don't know it
must be something very deep right
because it's it's saying that not only
do you get non-vanishing you don't get
zero anymore a rather important round
number as Julian Barbour used to say on
the podcast but you get this square root
of negative one why is that where does
that come from and then presumably I
don't know I mean you're the right
person to ask but I mean could you keep
going are there higher way order ways of
taking the analog of commutation
relations that would give you
quaternions and octonians and Clifford
algebras and I mean is there a whole
other set of reality I mean we just
think quantum mechanics is hard uh but
really it's just the analog of you know
the square root of negative one and we
know there's a lot more richness like
you just said SU 2. I don't know maybe
I'm just uh hopelessly out of my depth
here but uh I find that I think I think
it's a great question I I'm sort of
worried that if we're getting towards
the end of the podcast and I start
launching into something okay fair
enough you end up speaking let's do that
at part two so you'll write so I'm just
gonna say it's a it's a really I think
you're you've absolutely hit the nail on
the head it's a terrific question and uh
you know that's what we've got to focus
on all right great last uh two questions
really quickly
um so uh Arthur said things like for
every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert uh but he also said when
distinguished but elderly scientist
states that something is possible they
are almost certainly right when they say
something is impossible they are very
probably wrong what if anything I'm not
calling you elderly but what if anything
have you changed your mind on recently
or most pronouncedly in your life
in science well okay I'll give you an
example and and I say this
um you know you you've probably had the
same experience as me or maybe not maybe
all your papers have been published you
know with with minor only minor comments
uh from the referees but very rarely but
occasionally we have papers where the
referee says this paper shouldn't be
published you know should reject and our
initial reaction is to say oh this guy
is an idiot you know how do they choose
oh I say him you know him or her yeah
um but I have to say there's one
occasion where I'm just so happy that
the referee rejected the paper and this
was
um you know when the ozone hole was
discovered
uh by balloon measurements uh over
Antarctica
it kind of took Everyone by surprise
because
people had uh predicted that ozone was
being destroyed by the
you know the chlorofluorocarbons from
aerosols and so on but then you know
since we spray most of the stuff in the
northern hemisphere surely it would be
the the ozone over the Arctic that would
be destroyed
so I kind of thought well okay this
probably suggests to me that this isn't
actually a a human uh effect but it's
something in the Dynamics of the uh
southern hemisphere climate that's
causing this ozone hole so I wrote a
paper with uh with a colleague and sent
it to Nature making a kind of hypothesis
that it was caused by uh some ocean it
started off in the ocean the southern
oceans and then the effect propagated up
in the stratosphere and the circulation
uh changes affected the ozone and stuff
and um
it wasn't rigorous but we sent it to
Nature and it was rejected and of course
at the time I was incensed you know but
nature yeah it wouldn't I mean once you
once your papers rejected by Nature you
that's it you know forget it but my God
am I happy that it was because this was
completely wrong I mean it turned out
that it was actually caused by uh human
uh aerosol you know emissions uh and it
was a kind of complicated chemical
reaction that only happened in the
southern hemisphere because the
stratosphere is so much colder in the
southern hemisphere than the Northern
Hemisphere so the temperatures weren't
cold enough for this chemical reaction
to happen in the northern hemisphere so
that was something where I was
completely wrong and uh I was so happy
in who it is never made the light of day
good those are the kind of uh errors
you'd like to be wrong about like
Einstein his biggest blunder
um turned out to be a great discovery
okay last question Tim and I thank you
so much I know it's getting late they're
going backwards in time Arthur C
Clarke's third law states the only way
of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them into the impossible that's the
origin name of the podcast I want to ask
you we have a lot of young scientists
that listen to this show in their 20s
and 30s
um what advice would you give to a young
Tim Palmer back in that Epoch of your
life
um decades ago to give you the
confidence the Courage the Charisma to
go into the impossible as you've done
advice to your former self
well uh I guess there are two things
um I would say
uh one is read broadly because I am a
great believer in
that sort of 90
something percent of new ideas in a
particular field come because somebody
has made it the connection with with
some technique that's used in a
different field
so uh read broadly don't get too siled
you know into one particular
thing and the other thing is which which
kind of comes back to uh what we were
talking about about the brain and and
creativity I mean if it is the case that
you have your Eureka moments when you
are
uh relaxing then make sure you give
yourself enough time to do that I mean
don't spend the whole day in stuck in
front of your laptop or your desktop
computer or something just kind of
agonizing about
some piece of code or some equation or
other you know make sure you have time
to do nothing because it's that's when
as long as you've got the background you
know your brain needs the
needs the basic material there to make
the connections but
the brain does its own thing when making
those connections and just give it the
time to do that and if you're just all
spending day and night just focusing
your concentration on some scientific
problem you're not going to solve it
so uh you know don't uh
yeah lead a balanced life I would say
don't get don't get don't get sort of uh
you know seduced into spending 20 hours
a day focusing on some Arcane problem
pick up a guitar a banjo absolutely a
cricket paddle absolutely a golf club
you have so many interesting uh
instruments in the back I can't believe
you're not a string theorist uh Tim
Palmer uh such an incredible polymath
it's true
um this book uh written uh with such um
with such I'll show you the Oxford this
is the oup version it's got a slight
okay front cover so if you're reading
this in the UK or Europe or some way
very nice you can you have a slightly
different cover different cover same
content bag and content has all the use
and the flavor and neighborhood and all
those good things
um it makes a worthy compliment to this
book look it has a butterfly on the on
the front of it uh you appear in this
book very prominently and uh Sabina uh
kindly appears on the cover at least in
endorsing with her heartiest in chromium
uh of this book Tim you are a polymath
incredibly impressive I I would like to
spend more time at some point maybe at
an occasion of your next book or when
I'm in the UK I'm supposed to be there
next year I come and visit and I'd love
to talk about uh yeah I hear you play
those instruments in the background that
would be such a treat and so now I want
to thank you and wish you a wonderful
evening over there across the pond and
hope uh for the best of success and
congratulations in my heartiest sense on
this wonderful book it's really a joy to
read I devoured it in both formats and
listeners should as well thank you Tim
thank you Brian it's very kind of you
thank you any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic
foreign
[Music]